[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
the best things in life are free
according to the first line of a famous
motown song
as far as i know no chance of the
exchequer has ever sung that verse
healthcare education defense energy
transport just about anything we need
costs the keeper of the government's
purse and collector of taxes is more
likely to be belting out the chorus give
me money
this week rishi sunak reveals his latest
budget some of it we know cash for early
years for education and for transport
but is it going to be enough and even if
it is
who's paying
and can we be sure about anything with
covet still sweeping the land
our guest this morning may help us find
out
in just a moment i'll speak to the man
himself chancellor rishi sunak will join
me and we'll look at his plans for the
taxes you'll pay and how he'll spend the
money
we'll also hear from his opposite number
rachel reeves who'll need to respond to
the budget and spending review on
wednesday never an easy task
with much of the focus on that phrase
again levelling up and transport
spending in cities across england we'll
speak to west yorkshire mayor tracy
brabin well the other big story exercise
in mind here in westminster is the
resurgence of kovid and concerns about
the booster vaccine rollout so we'll
speak to professor adam finn who sits on
the joint committee on vaccination and
immunization
and fears about rising covet
hospitalizations plus the usual wins to
stresses mean hospitals and staff are
already under huge pressure so we'll
speak to the president of the royal
college of emergency medicine catherine
henderson but first let's focus on
wednesday's budget which will also
include announcements on the
government's spending plans for the next
three years so it really is a crucial
moment for chancellor rishi sunek who
joins me now good morning chancellor
good morning you've already announced
that there's going to be a 7 billion
pound for
new transport projects outside london
can you confirm that just one and a half
billion of that money hasn't been
announced
previously so the transport money that
we announced is a combination of two
things one we previously announced an
overall envelope to improve how people
get around our big cities we wanted our
cities whether that's in the west
midlands or in the in t side or greater
manchester to have the same type of
transport settlements that london's
always enjoyed where locally elected
mayors can take a pot of money and
decide how best to spend it to help all
their residents and we previously
announced 4.2 billion pounds for that
what we've actually done is top that up
as you said by a billion and a half
pounds but then crucially give out the
allocations for in that envelope where
are all the bits going to go so it's
going to create trams over here bus
links over here road improvements over
there so whether you're in west
yorkshire west midlands greater
manchester t-side local residents are
going to see improvements over the next
few years as their leaders are given the
same type of power and funding that
london has always enjoyed so it's a
great example of leveling up in practice
and it's ultimately just going to create
growth in all of these places okay so
that's a billion and a half's worth of
leveling up um we're going to talk to
tracy breben a bit later the mayor of uh
west yorkshire
can you assure her that the money that
she's going to get 830 million i think
uh will
uh
fund a new stop in bradford uh
from the new northern powerhouse rail
line plus an hs2 extension uh to leads
so more broadly and you'll speak to
tracy later and we had comments i think
yesterday whether it's from andy burnham
or indeed andy street in the west
midlands our local mayor's actually all
warmly welcoming i think the funding
that was announced everybody likes money
but let's see what it's gonna be i think
your specific question actually relates
to something different so what the money
announced yesterday was about is about
what we call inter-city transportation
that's about how do we get people who
live in and around a city to be able to
get into the middle of it and out again
easily we actually don't do as well as
we should do on that if you look at
cities like say marseille or lyon in
france it takes virtually no time at all
within half an hour for people to get
from the out to the inn
that that journey time in some of our
cities outside of london can take twice
as long and that's not great it's not
great for creating jobs not great for
people's quality of life that's what
we're trying to fix with these
settlements that we've announced what
you're talking about is something
different and that's about how we
connect up our towns and cities to each
other now that's going to be part of
something called the integrated rail
plan and plans for that will be
announced shortly but we have committed
to improving the links between all our
great cities across the north for
example between
liverpool manchester and leeds
bradford will will obviously be a part
of that as well yeah dan jarvis who uh
is the mayor in uh el dorado yorkshire
was saying yesterday that he's looking
forward to some money for the extension
of hs2 and tracy braven is quite
specific
whether it's this package of money this
weekend or what or the three year pack
spending review
she wants a step stop in bradford and
she wants hs2 to go delete is that going
to happen so that will be part of the
integrated rail plan which will spell
out our plans to connect up all our
towns and cities not just across the
north but also across the midlands it
wouldn't be right for me to to speculate
on that now but what i can tell you is
people will see enormous improvements in
journey times as we deliver what the
prime minister said when he was first
elected an infrastructure revolution in
this country
and why is this important because all
very well to talk about the money we're
spending it's important because it
creates jobs it creates prosperity if we
can better connect up our towns and
cities that's going to allow our economy
to grow it's going to increase
productivity and allow people to access
better paying jobs you know that's how
we build a stronger economy in this
country and that's what next week's
budget is all about it's about building
that stronger economy for the british
people okay we have to have people who
can do the jobs and you put some money
into skills and education let's start
let's start at the very beginning you
are
going to give 500 million years for
early years education now your
conservative predecessors cut the shore
start program by
about 1.2 billion pounds over the past
decade
is this 500 million an admission that
that was just a mistake
so what the this money is about is
actually addressing something probably
slight slightly different and there's
been enormous work being done and
predicted by one of my colleagues andrea
ledson and also fiona bruce and what
they've that what they've showed very
clearly as the evidence does that the
the very early years in young families
lives are critical and that's where
parents often struggle and that's where
actually we need to provide a little bit
more attention so what we're announcing
is funding to create a network of family
hubs which are broader than shaw start
centers and they bring together lots of
different services for new parents and
for the first time we're going to roll
those out and whether that's parenting
program support for for mental health
help with very very young children with
things like numeracy and literacy as
well all those types of things we can
bring together help young parents at a
difficult time we know that that will
make an enormous difference to those
parents and those young families lives
so i'm delighted that we're able
werewolves to do this and it's based on
a lot of evidence and research that's
been carried out over the last few years
which demonstrates this is an important
thing to do well your predecessor george
osborne who's really principally
responsible for taking a little bit more
than a billion pounds out of short start
i mean he's out of politics now so you
can say that was a mistake can't you no
i think it's right to judge everyone by
the context that they are doing their
jobs in and one thing that my
predecessors not just george did was
ensure that i actually had a very strong
economy and strong set of public
finances that i inherited and that was
really important because then when
coronavirus came which nobody knew about
i was able to respond in a comprehensive
and generous fashion to support families
businesses in the country through the
crisis and actually part of my
responsibility
it's an error
no way you could pick on individual
things but overall what my predecessors
did was deliver a strong economy and a
strong set of public finances which we
have now benefited from over the past
year as we've responded and protected
and supported people now part of my job
and part of what next week's budget is
about is doing that again it's
delivering that stronger economy that
stronger set of public finances because
whenever the next difficult thing comes
along i want to make sure whoever's
sitting in this chair can do what i did
over the last year and that's the right
thing for the country it's the right
thing for the british people to have
that stronger economy to fall back on
well let's let's keep talking about the
spending because there's quite a lot of
it you're announcing a skills package
worth three billion pounds now a lot of
this just replaces funds we would have
got from the eu structural funds anyway
but um where exactly is the new money in
that three billion pound package
so what you'll see all the details of
this laid out this week now there are
we've talked a lot about building a
high-wage economy now the best way to do
that is to give people opportunities to
retrain to upskill at any stage in their
lives and then get really well paid jobs
as a result of that and we've got a
suite of interventions to do that the
prime minister's lifetime skills
guarantee is one i could pick on as an
example we have around 10 million adults
in this country who sadly don't have the
equivalent of a level three
qualification and an a-level equivalent
qualification now for the first time
the government will pay for those people
to get that qualification that's worth
almost 3 000 pounds a year in cost but
we know if we do that those people are
much more likely to get a job and earn
more money so that's one of the most
important and powerful things we can do
to help people earn more create a better
life for them and their families that's
why skills are important and it's all
part of building that stronger economy
that i talked about and that's what
you'll see next week one of the biggest
issues in building a strong economy is
productivity now um
here's a problem
pretty much every year we look at this
whoever's chancellor trumpets some huge
sum for skills training
to increase productivity
the ifs estimates that over the past 10
years we've spent
39.8
billion pounds into adult training
and skills
and here's what happened as a result i
wanted to show you this uh to the effect
on productivity i'm going to show you a
graph
which
says shows the increase in productivity
over the last decade
the inde increases productivity is as
near zero as dammit
until you've deci worked out why that
money isn't making any difference aren't
we just throwing good money after bed
no there's lots of different things that
go into increasing our productivity our
plan for growth that we've set out
involves investing in infrastructure
innovation and skills i think of it like
that so infrastructure we've talked a
little bit about actually earlier on in
the program that's going to help drive
up our productivity not to get technical
about it there's something called
agglomeration economics making sure that
our cities can perform at their highest
potential so those investments will help
us do that we know that they would play
all the clever people and all the
productive people in one place no it's
not so much about the clever people for
a given city for it to maximize its
potential we may need to make it easy
for people to move around it so that's
what those investments will do and we
know that economically that will make a
difference so that's the infrastructure
piece for example skills we've just
talked about and giving people the tools
they need to get better jobs and we've
got a range of things that we're doing
there that we haven't done before
actually the prime minister's lifetime
skills guarantee is new things like
skills boot camps are new in this
country working with hundreds of
employers to design three to four month
courses with a job interview at the end
with proper employer engagement during
the training these are new interventions
and we think they're going to make a big
difference and then the last piece is
innovation is how do we build a high
innovation economy that's going to be
ready to embrace some of the
technological change we're seeing so
there it's investing in r d it's making
sure our growing companies can get the
capital they need it's about making sure
we attract talented people from abroad
it's about helping our companies grow so
our help to grow program again we've
never done something like this before
it's giving small and medium-sized
companies mini mbas support with digital
technology i'm confident that all of
those things are going to raise their
productivity and that chart that we saw
will will start to tick up but chanter
is there a big elephant in the room here
i mean you're saying all of this and
you're offering the money and so on is
one of the reasons that nothing changes
is that in spite of all this money for
training
fi the apprenticeship levy huge 2.7
billion i think
5000 employers don't use it 400 million
worth of that levy
expired we understand last year and
isn't the problem really the one that
the prime minister and also your
colleague the home secretary frequently
talk about which is that as long as
employers can bring in cheap
labor through immigration they aren't
going to invest in training and skills
and raise productivity in the way that
you want it to be raised
well i wouldn't say that nothing has
changed and actually i think some of the
things that we've already put in place
are starting to yield benefits
that graph is over the last 10 years but
let me just look at the time that i've
had this job and what we're seeing now
what we're seeing is record numbers of
job vacancies we're seeing employers
wanting to hire we're seeing businesses
intentions to invest growing again
partly aided by measures that we've
taken like the super deduction which is
a huge tax incentive for businesses to
invest in increasing their productivity
and we're seeing people's wages rise uh
real wages today are three and a half
percent higher than they were before the
crisis so actually all the things that
we put in place the plan for jobs that
i've been on this show talking about a
lot over the last year and a half that
plan for jobs is working people are
seeing the benefits of it and i'm
confident that if we continue to deliver
on investing and infrastructure
innovation our skills we will see our
growth rise and next week's budget will
demonstrate that plan in action we will
build that stronger economy we'll drive
up our economic growth and productivity
and people are going to feel that in
higher living standards and a better
quality of life all right let's let's
talk about what some of your colleagues
in the conservative party say which is
that you're not really a very
conservative chancellor at all um
you said in
the uh prime minister said in your pa in
the party conference that um you would
be first government in decades not to
dock these hard decisions you'd be
radical and optimistic let's see if
that's actually true
for example nobody wants to keep the
system of business rates
you said in your 2019 uh
manifesto that we will cut the burden of
tax on business by reducing business
rates and you promised a fundamental
review two years now are you going to be
telling us on wednesday that you're
going to get rid of business right well
i will talk on on wednesday about the
conclusion of that fundamental review so
it wouldn't be appropriate for me to do
that it's actually concluded so yeah yes
we will get an outcome from this we will
get an outcome from the review we've
said that we would conclude the review
in the autumn and you'll see that i mean
but on business rates important remember
this is a government that's put in place
the small business rates reduction which
means a third of all properties don't
pay any business rates at all any more
and over the past year and a half
through chronovirus we've delivered
about 16 billion pounds worth of tax
cuts on business rates to help
hospitality and retail businesses get
through all of this and
in terms of the review and and
reform i think you've got the shadow
chancellor on uh later on in the show i
mean there are people who say you should
just abolish business rates which i
think is what the labour party position
is business rates obviously
yeah this rate obviously does raise 25
billion pounds i'm sure you'll be asking
her well what is the system that would
replace that if you are going to just
stand up and say you're going to abolish
it that's okay i'll do that
what about your yours
we've delivered short-term relief during
the last 18 months through chronovirus
that support extends through to next
year we'll be talking a little bit more
about the future and some things that we
can do in business rates next week in
the budget but that's all part of a
budget that as i said it builds a
stronger economy and you will see us
supporting business and there are lots
of different ways to support business
business rates is one of them incentives
to invest like our super deduction the
biggest ever tax cut for businesses that
this country's seen and that's creating
a strong climate for investment and
that's going to create jobs as well
helping small companies with mini mbas
digital skills help to grow i mentioned
helping them take on new staff young
people through the kickstart scheme a
lot of different things we're doing to
help business
but you understand where where i'm going
here because
it reported that this week
the former prime minister david cameron
told
mr johnson that at least in my day we
cut taxes you are not doing that at all
you're presiding over the highest tax
burden since post-war period and we can
have another look at this the ifs says
that
you've got a sustained level of public
spending 42 of gdp and it's the highest
since 1985 and actually look at the
graph since oh
the post-war period 1950
you're still
pretty high 35 percent that's not the
low tax conservatism that the prime
minister promised and you yourself said
you stand for
yes and of course i do stand for that
and that's what i would want to deliver
and that's where my instincts are but
you also have to take a step back trevor
and think well what have i and the
government had to grapple with over the
past year and a half we've had
the biggest economic shock that we've
experienced in 300 years
we've had the need rightly to come and
support the country through that which
has obviously been enormously costly it
drove our borrowing up to levels we
haven't seen since world war ii just on
the other side of that uh chart
and we've got a strong ambition to
invest in public services and drive up
our growth by investing in
infrastructure innovation and skills all
the things that we've talked about
earlier so those are the things i'm
grappling with and i and i've got to
take the world as it comes you know i
wish i hadn't had to deal with
coronavirus in a once in 300 year
economic shock and all the damage that
has done to our economy uh and an nhs
backlog that was stretching into the
millions that we thought it was really
important rightly to get some funding in
to address so but those are the
challenges that i'm grappling with and i
have to take those challenges and figure
out what's the right way to do that and
we've made some decisions which i
believe although they are difficult are
the right decisions they're the
responsible decisions and ultimately
we'll deliver on the things that people
want to see us deliver on and indeed
build that strong economy for the future
which is going to drive growth and raise
our living standards
to sum up what johnson-ism
in the economic terms right now looks
like is typeface can fiscal control
squeeze on every department except maybe
health
lots of universal credit 20 up 20 pounds
uplift prospect of inflation at four
percent uh and by the way
uh
more on less on public services when
there's more demand less in wage packets
when uh prices are going up now
offer some of your colleagues at least
some hope that that isn't the totality
of johntonism and that there might be
some tax cuts
well what i tell you is this our focus
over the last year year and a half has
been on delivering our plan for jobs i'm
pleased to say that plan has worked with
far fewer people unemployed than we
feared the economy recovering faster
than people thought so that's good news
that plan for jobs has worked and
looking forward next week's budget is
about the future it's about building
that stronger economy for our country
you've asked what does that mean well it
means a few things it actually means
very strong continued investment in
public services it means driving our
future economic growth by investing in
infrastructure innovation and skills the
things we've talked about it means
giving businesses confidence through all
the things we're going to do to support
them and lastly it means supporting
working families and as we have done
through the last year there lots of
different ways to support working
families but those things combined are
what deliver a stronger economy for the
british people and that's what next
week's budget is going to do okay give
your colleague somehow rule out tax
rises before the next election trevor
you you're asking me to do my budget
live on your show which although it
would be great well because i would do
it in parliament on wednesday all right
um one last question we have cop 26 next
week one things we know is no presidency
no president putin
no new restrictions on fossil fuels if
the australians and the chinese and to
some extent the saudis though they're
making a gesture uh say uh would would
uh have have it
um
it's a bit of a shambles isn't it no i
think that's
not right at all if you look at when we
first took on the presidency of cop i
think about 30 percent of the global
economy had climate targets in place
thanks in part to the great work of the
prime minister and the cop president
alex sharma that number has now gone up
to 80
because there's a team of people
demonstrating uk leadership on the world
stage to try and get more people to sign
up to target so i think that's actually
a great success story before we've even
got to the summit in glasgow and you
know what you're going to see
particularly on on the bit that i'm
responsible for for example the finance
side of it i'm hosting a full day on
wednesday we're having great turnout
from finance ministers and financial
companies from around the world
committed to transforming our financial
system to make it
fit for the future to help with the
transition and there's great news there
if you look at london just this week the
uk has been named best place in the
world for green finance we issued our
second sovereign green bond which now
makes us the largest uh those are the
third largest issuer of sovereign green
bonds anywhere in the world and we've
only been going a month so you know
actually there's there's lots there's
lots to celebrate and actually i think
coffee will be a big success okay
chancellor thank you we're looking for
i'm looking forward to i know you're a
music fan looking forward to seeing what
you think on wednesday thank you very
much thank you now responding to the
budget as the opposition is never easy
you don't have sight of the plans for
long and you don't have the treasury's
beam counters to help you
but the election could be as little as
18 months away and if labor wants to be
seen as a government in waiting it'll
need to give us some specifics at times
like this so let's give shadow
chancellor rachel reeves the chance to
just do that now
good morning good morning shadow
chancellor
um
presumably you welcome the seven billion
pounds worth of investment which
incidentally is going to benefit uh your
uh constituency of lee in leeds
well let's hope so but what we see from
this government is lots of announcements
and much less delivery northern
powerhouse rail that would benefit leeds
and bradford and manchester and other
towns and cities across yorkshire was
first announced seven years ago
it's been announced 60 times since then
and there's still not a single spade in
the ground
or train on the rails
it's not good enough and the government
are going to make more announcements
this week
but we're sick of in the north having
announcements without the delivery on
the ground and we want to see
concrete action
to match the rhetoric of this government
that's really important for all of us in
the north of england
but your your labor colleagues uh tracy
braven and andy burnham have been rather
positive about this announcement um in
fact uh andy burnham said yesterday
uh this is not a day for negativity um
aren't you being a bit mean
well of course new money is welcome but
as i say trevor it's got to be backed up
with actual action and northern
powerhouse rail the eastern leg of hs2
the dismal state that many of our bus
services in with cuts over the last few
years and higher fares all of those
things need addressing and it's it's of
course welcome always to have more
investment
but if that investment isn't backed up
with actual delivery
it's really not worth the paper it's
written on and that is the frustration
in many towns and cities across the
north of england the while big grand
projects get delivered elsewhere in the
country they're few and far between in
our towns and cities and northern
powerhouse rail i think is the best
example
of a huge gaping chasm now between the
rhetoric of the government and the
actual delivery for people on the ground
okay well look would you give a tick at
least to the 500 million for early years
education which is a thing i know from
your parliamentary career that you care
about quite a lot
i just would say to the chancellor have
you ever heard of surestart
because that is what your governments
over the last 11 years have cut and it's
all well and good saying we're going to
invest in these family parks
but thousands of children centers and
shore start centers
that were proud features of our
communities especially some of our
poorest communities
have long gone
and tessa jowl and harriet harman and
vet cooper and others in previous labour
governments who made those happen
i i think there's a real feeling that if
you hadn't have taken all that away
imagine what difference it could have
made to the lives of young people and to
their parents
and this pale imitation which doesn't
even take us back to where we were in
i think is an insult to all those people
who created investment and made sure
start happen in the first place and it
was such a proud achievement of the last
labour government
and it really was an act of criminality
to rip that all up
only to now 11 years later create a pale
imitation of it
i am frequently uh saying to you and
your colleagues um what would you do and
complaining that you don't give me an
answer but in fact this morning you've
already said that um
you would cut vat on domestic
energy supplies at a cost you estimate
of a billion pounds um i think that's
interesting
who's going to tell andy burnham that
if you were chancellor he wouldn't be
getting the transport um improvements
which coincidentally cost about a
billion pounds because you want to spend
it uh on uh energy
well no one would have to say that sir
andy burnham i would say to andy burnham
we'll invest in the transport in greater
manchester and across the north england
and give you the powers
to do that because too many decisions
are still made in whitehall and
westminster and not in the towns and
cities and regions of our country and we
want to devolve more powers to andy to
tracy to dan jarvis and to our other
great metro mayors around the country
we've been clear about how we would pay
for this cut in vit but let me just say
why it's so important but people have
been facing now a tough winter with the
prices of everything going up not least
our gas and electricity bills and
everybody is feeling the pinch
when we pay our gas and electricity
bills each month five percent of that
bill goes directly to the tax man
and what labour are saying
is let's reduce that rate of vat on gas
and electricity bills from five percent
to zero percent for six months to get us
through this winter period and that
would be an immediate and automatic
reduction
to the bills of every single family and
pensioner across our country
and we would pay for that by using
the vat receipts that have come in
higher than forecast highland forecast
by over 2 billion pounds over the last
two months not least because prices are
so much higher than they were forecast
let's use that additional revenue that
has flowed into the treasury these last
few months to make that important
reduction in vat on gas and electricity
bills to ease that pressure on people
who are struggling right now with the
rising cost of living at the same time
that taxes are going up
but i suspect that that um that extra
money has already been allocated
elsewhere in the chancellor's plan so um
if you're not going to
find it from
andy's money or tracy brabian's 830
million or the 830 million for the fe
skills budget or t levels
where is this actually going to be or is
this the magic money tree turning up
again
trevor you're asking me what labour
would do if it was our budget on
wednesday and our priority would be
easing the cost of living price um
crisis helping businesses who have had a
torrid 18 months and addressing some of
the long-term challenges that we face
with climate crisis but also our plans
to buy make and sell more in britain and
if it was our budget on wednesday we
would be using those additional vat
receipts to cut v80 on gas and
electricity bills because we know what a
difficult time so many families and also
pensioners are facing whatever
with worries about rising prices and
worries about rising gas electricity
bills and that is labour's priority and
that is what labour would do at the
moment i'm sorry to interrupt you
chancellor but you last time you were on
you told me that um
you would abolish business rates at a
stroke that will cost 25 billion pounds
okay you might be able to find a little
bit of underspending and so on but it's
not going to count to 25 billion pounds
you haven't got the money
on business rates what we've said is
that next year instead of increasing
business rates like this government plan
to do we would freeze business rates for
all and we would extend the small
business rates relief and we would pay
for that by increasing the digital
services tax on firms who have done well
these latin a last 18 months as people's
spending patterns have changed that
would bring in just over 2 billion
pounds and that would enable us to
freeze rates and extend smaller business
rates relief but we know these problems
run deeper than
just some tinkering around the edges in
one year only and that's why labour have
committed to abolish business rates and
replace it with a fairer form of
business property taxation
what do i mean by that
first of all i mean
if you wouldn't small businesses
the high street businesses and small
businesses shouldn't have to bear such a
disproportionate burden of business
rates
out of town warehouses for example are
attacked at a much lower rate than high
street businesses but we've also got a
situation okay where some of our big
digital companies are not paying
corporation tax in this country the
global minimum rate of corporation tax
the receipts from that should ease the
burden of business rates on high street
and small businesses that's okay
labour's priority i'm sorry sorry to
stop you getting chance but we have been
over that ground before but anyway i'm
grateful to you for your time this
morning thank you very much indeed
thank
you okay now
get a vaccine to keep your freedoms that
was the rather chilling warning from the
health secretary this week as he warned
people to get booster jabs as covert
cases could soon hit 100 000 per day
the prime minister has issued what he
says is a call to arms to encourage
people to get a booster amid real
concern about the pace of the program
and whether we may now be headed for
further restrictions
so let's speak to professor adam finn he
sits on the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization which makes
decisions about vaccinations um
adam finn we're seeing rising infection
numbers but hospitalizations aren't
keeping
pace uh
does it really matter if we hit 100 000
or 50 000 or whatever it is
of infections if the hospitalizations
aren't rising
uh but unfortunately they are rising and
and so the numbers of deaths and and
they will go up as the number of cases
go up because the virus will reach
people who are vulnerable and
who may get seriously ill so i think you
know we we can't be complacent about
this that this is a worsening situation
in an nhs which is all already under
enormous pressure
we are hearing a great deal about waning
immunity how serious a problem do you
think that is
uh i think it exists uh i think we are
seeing uh an increased risk particularly
amongst older people who were immunized
the longest time ago at the beginning of
the year
with an increasing risk that they may be
hospitalized actually they're still
relatively well protected but of course
there are large numbers of people and
with very high levels of spread of the
virus they are beginning to
show up in hospital the biggest risk of
course is amongst those who have not
been vaccinated at all including younger
adults not just older people who may who
may get sick and many of the
hospitalized people we're seeing at the
moment are in fact unimmunized people
so the for you the the issue is still
getting everybody jabbed
uh i think that the the vaccine program
uh is doing a lot to make the situation
much less severe than it would otherwise
be
and the vaccines principally are very
effective at stopping people from
getting seriously ill
they're not so effective unfortunately
at stopping infections altogether or
stopping the virus from being spread
about they do have an effect on that
but they're not by themselves going to
be enough at the present time to keep to
keep the spread of the virus under
control and we do need to see people
continuing to make efforts to avoid
contact to avoid transmission
and to do other things as well as get
vaccinated if we're going to stop this
rise from going up further
let us clarify one thing about the
vaccination program the prime minister's
pinning pretty much all his hopes on
that success
um
do you think he is right
to float the idea of an extension of the
booster program
to under 50s
and by offering jobs at five months
rather than the current six months and
one week
uh i think we need to be careful that we
stick to the science here that
just giving more people vaccines uh
including people who maybe don't
actually need the vaccines yet
can could actually run the risk of
making things worse rather than better
if you boost people before they actually
need the vaccine it is in some sense as
a waste of vaccine but also it means
that you're immunizing them earlier and
they may make a smaller response to the
vaccine and that response may wear off
earlier
so i think the idea of just getting more
doses into indiscriminately into
people's arms is not really necessarily
going to solve the problem i think we do
need to focus particularly on the most
elderly people
and do this in a structured and
strategic way in order to have the
maximum impact
so to be clear you wouldn't
move to five months but you would focus
on vulnerable groups could you
elaborate on
who you're thinking of
yes certainly the the the strategy for
the booster program is somewhat similar
to the strategy first time around in
other words to start with the oldest
people first
and work our way down through the age
groups and at the same time focused on
people who are particularly high risk
who are younger so it really does mirror
what we did first time around
and we do need to do it in that order in
order to have the maximum impact
as you get younger and younger you're
getting to people who've got stronger
and stronger immune responses and who
have been immunized more and more
recently and so you get to a law of
diminishing returns to a point where
you're really not achieving anything at
all you're just using up your resources
to boost people who don't actually need
boosters at this time
but i would like to re-emphasize the
fact that the vaccine program by itself
in the current situation even if things
go optimally it is not in my opinion
enough to bring things under control we
do need to have people using lateral
flow tests
avoiding
contact with large numbers of people in
enclosed spaces using masks all of those
things now need to happen if we're going
to stop this rise and get things under
control soon enough to stop a real
meltdown in the middle of the winter
professor finn that sounds pretty
clearly like
you think i know you're not responsible
for making policy but that you think we
should move to plan b
now
well some kind of plan b what i think we
should stop doing and i think we did
hear this from the secretary of state
from health last week is a recognition
uh that that giving the message to the
population that the prop the problem's
all over and that there's no need for
any further
restrictions or efforts being made to
reduce transmission of infection is
sending out the wrong message um and i i
worry in fact that the vaccine program
itself is suffering as a consequence of
this suggestion that somehow the
problem's gone and we can all go back to
normal again uh because that will
increasingly make people drunk to the
conclusion that they've not been
vaccinated there's no real need to do it
so i do think we need to see a very
different kind of message coming from
the government now that there is a
serious problem and we all need to
continue to contribute to reducing
transmission so that we can get through
the winter and the and the nhs can stay
afloat and absolutely we can avoid
lockdowns and the disasters that those
bring we all want to avoid that but we
can't avoid it if we all just go back to
normal now
and would a clear way of sending that
message be
to reimpose some restrictions
mask wearing for example uh
staying away from workplaces for example
well as you said it's not my job to
create policy i think this needs to be
brought about whether it can be brought
about by clear messaging and
communication i think the british public
are
for by and large a pretty responsible
lot and if you give them a clear message
of what you want them to do they will
they will pay attention to that
whether it's that sufficient or whether
it actually needs to be done by
compelling people i think that is a
decision for the politicians but one way
or another we do need to bring about a
situation where there is less
transmission of virus going on in the
community and we can't just rely on the
vaccine program to achieve that
can i ask a a broader question are you
more worried at the moment about
unvaccinated uh individuals
or about resurgence of covid
or about the
problem of conventional flu given that
there's less certainty this year about
the efficacy of the flu vaccine
uh well i don't see those things as
alternatives i think they're all true um
so i i'm particularly worried about the
number of adults that have not been
vaccinated uh i'm perplexed that there
are so many such people because they are
a very important group when it comes to
the the number of serious illnesses
we're seeing the pressure on the
hospitals and of course they are all
personally at great risk of serious
illness and even death so those are
people that i think we really do need to
be concerned about
and we need to focus on the communities
where coverage is low
and do everything we can to make vaccine
readily available and to make clear
information available to people so they
can make the sensible decision to get
immunized
i do think we're seeing covert cases
rising at the moment not so rapidly in
terms of severe cases as before but of
course in terms of cases overall very
large numbers and i'm very concerned
about flu this year as is as as everyone
else because we had no flu last year to
speak of the population is more
susceptible to flu
and that on top of everything else now
we're mixing together uh could really
significantly add to the pressure on the
health service so the flu vaccine just
kicking off is really important too
professor finn thank you very much
indeed
thanks a lot nice talking to you
it is getting colder winter's close and
there are fears about an nhs crisis
again
nothing new there it is different this
time in one respect fears around the new
covered wave we've just been discussing
uh bad flu season backlogs from the last
18 months emergency departments are the
front line often with ambulances parked
up outside them waiting to offload
patients
catherine henderson is the president of
the royal college of emergency medicine
she joins me now
dr henderson
are you happy with the pro prospect of
uh all nhs staff being compelled to have
two jabs or being dismissed that as
we're reading this
morning um so that's not something that
i would um be giving a uh anything other
than a personal opinion at the moment we
would like staff to be vaccinated
because we know that that will give them
protection and that we've see we've seen
during the waves that um
health care workers are very much in the
front line of the risks as well as the
treatment of the pandemic so yes i'm
keen that people are
getting vaccinated and that needs to be
clear to them and also to be honest
getting the booster because actually
that's the next layer is getting a
booster as well so
you know personally i would be saying to
everybody think very very carefully
about not doing this because this puts
your health at risk and therefore then
additionally puts your patients at risk
so as a professional
uh
view of this would be to get vaccinated
i ask i ask that because of course
anything that puts extra pressure
on the department where you and your
colleagues work
of course could tip us over the edge
do you think that emergency departments
given the situation as it is now and
what we know
are going to be able to cope this winter
we're already already struggling to cope
it's this is not something that's coming
in the next you know couple of months
we're already in a terrible place where
we have got large queues of ambulances
with vulnerable people waiting in those
ambulances to be offloaded into
departments and other patients at home
waiting to be picked up by the ambulance
that's the thing that really worries me
that these are patients who've not yet
received treatment that we don't
necessarily know what's wrong with them
that we're really struggling to get into
our healthcare facilities to then work
out what we need to do that's the real
worry from my point of view and we're
already in that situation
what do you need to alleviate the
problem we need to have beds so the
biggest problem is exit block both from
an emergency department into hospital
wards and from hospital wards back out
into the community so we need to be able
to get all patients who are fit to not
be in hospital back out so the primary
thing that we need is to establish
enough space in community facilities or
enough community support so patients can
be in their own homes so that we don't
have patients in hospital who could be
being cared for in a different
environment that then works itself back
towards the front line so that instead
of patients being stuck in emergency
departments what we call exit block from
from the emergency department
we can get them out of the department
and we can get new patients into our
cubicles it's a whole system problem
which happens to be bottlenecked in the
emergency department and therefore very
visible on the ambulance ramp
if nothing changes
can you talk to us about the seriousness
of this i mean is this
an inconvenience or are we seeing
people at risk of essentially dying
because
uh the system is blocked up
the system is incredibly busy at the
moment when we're already ready reaching
a point where 999 ambulance call
handling is delayed so it's that you
don't get an immediate answer to the
phone when you ring that 999 it takes
time to get an ambulance that push puts
patients at risk because you don't know
what's wrong with them you don't know
what is on the end of the phone is it
some a patient who needs care
immediately as a you know blue light
ambulance or is it somebody who can
afford to wait 20 30 40 minutes um
before they're reached but the same is
true on the ambulance ramp unless we can
get patients in and actually assess them
so that is risk of real patient harm and
patients dying so it actually really
matters this is not about an
inconvenience this is not about being
patient because of a long wait
this is about people who could come to
significant harm if we're not getting
the care to them that they need because
there's just so many people in the
system you can't spot the needle in the
haystack
one of the issues which seems to have
arisen is the question of whether people
can go to
their gps or not and get face-to-face
consultation if they can't they turn up
an a and e
um
do you think that there is any
issue
uh with that and might you need to say
to your gp colleagues that it's time for
them
uh to see more people face to face as
the secretary of state seems to be
suggesting
primary care is under enormous pressure
as well but the patients that we're
really worried about in the emergency
care system are not patients who are
getting or needing necessarily a gp
appointment they're they're sickest
patients we're most worried about the
most vulnerable patients and those are
the patients who are coming in by
ambulance by and large rather than it
being an issue with primary care
patients yes we get we get stories of
patients who've tried to get in touch
with primary care and then maybe have
come to us but that's not the main
pressure the main pressure is people who
need admission and not having a bed for
them to get to that's where our problems
lie in is in exit block rather than just
the volume
um i i'm not going to invite you to be
overly dramatic uh dr henderson but
everything you have told me this morning
adds up to
one uh simple statement
that it looks and sounds like and feels
like
that may be people who are dying today
because of the crisis that you and your
members are uh facing
we we know that crowding is harmful to
patients
we were crowded in emergency departments
pre-pandemic you said at the beginning
of this it's winter another winter
crisis you know what's new i mean sadly
that is true
we didn't go into the pandemic in a
great place in emergency care we didn't
have enough beds then the problem is
that things are worse at the moment so
we need everybody to be as careful with
the healthcare resources as they
possibly can be and try and minimize the
need for healthcare resources so if
we've got 8 000 patients in hospital who
are suffering covet if we didn't have
those patients that would be another 8
000 beds in the system so every bed that
gets filled by a patient with covert in
a sense is in a hospital bed with a
potentially avoidable disease and that's
what we need people to focus on if we
want to get through the elective backlog
everybody will know somebody who's on
that list we won't be able to do that
unless we've got the beds to put those
patients in so if we can get covert
levels down if we can make sure that the
vulnerable don't get infected and then
need hospital care if we can make sure
that we don't have people who are
severely ill because they catch it when
they're unvaccinated
all of that will help we're all in this
together to try and make it better
uh dr henderson thank you very much
indeed
thank you
now that
the treasury has
the treasury has already told us where
almost six billion pounds worth of
funding for transport improvement in
english cities is going to go
west yorkshire is getting
830 million pounds this is what the
mayor of the region had to say
i welcome the 830 million pounds but i
will be pushing for more it's good news
that government's finally giving us the
boost which means we can start work on
providing the transport system the
people of west yorkshire deserve
well sounds like tracy brabian's fairly
happy with what she's going to hear in
wednesday's budget so
let's ask her now live from huddersfield
tracy braven the chancellor says he's
sending you a really big wad
um you must be pretty cheerful this
morning
well good morning trevor yes it is good
news and certainly i'm pleased that
governments are
chiming with us about our ambitions for
our region but as you heard from rachel
earlier in your program this is only one
part of the jigsaw we can't talk about
levelling up if we don't talk about
another
rail line the northern powerhouse rail
that'll have that stop at st james's in
bradford bradford is one of the youngest
cities in the whole country we want to
connect those young people to jobs and
opportunities but of course hs2 we've
had briefings and counter briefings and
rumors we absolutely need to know that
that is going to happen we need that new
station in leeds leeds already is at
capacity we have the land allocated we
have the ambition for it we are ready to
live to
deliver as labour mayors and um i'm glad
government see the uh the opportunity
and we're happy to work with them
well i don't know if you heard my
interview with the chancellor earlier uh
tracy braven but um
when i asked him about the stop in
bradford and the extension to lead
he was um at best i would say enigmatic
he didn't
he didn't embrace the opportunity to say
ah yes and of course look out for an
announcement on that um
not really that good news
well we've been waiting for the
integrated rail plan as you heard from
the from the chancellor for quite some
time i've been pressing for more
information but i was at the global
investment summit only last week and
heard the prime minister talk
specifically about northern powerhouse
rail but what's important for us is that
stop in bradford we can't have a
watered-down version of our transport
network here in west yorkshire we have
had 174 pounds per head spent on
transport in london it's over 500 pounds
we have less per head than any other
community across the country we've been
underfunded for decades now is the
opportunity for government to be bold to
be ambitious to come with us with our
vision for west yorkshire to have that
london style
transport system that will really make
us that powerhouse we can be
so you you rather share rachel reeves
skepticism that says
uh this is an announcement
but we're not seeing delivery yet
well we're still waiting for the detail
i think there is tension potentially
between number 10 and number 11 between
maybe what the prime minister wants to
see and what rishi sunak thinks that he
can afford but actually it's going to
cost us all not to deliver a gold-plated
five-star transport system for west
yorkshire
uh can i ask about another aspect of the
spending um program um the skills pro
proposal um there's a lot of money going
to be spent on skills and i guess a lot
of some of it will go to
your towns your fe colleges and so on
but do you worry that you will be
training people in bradford and
wakefield just so that they can hop on a
new rail line if you get it to work in
manchester
no that's not necessarily the whole
picture because when it comes to skills
obviously we want young people to choose
their first
choice of college and not have to choose
their third because they can't get to
their first because there's poor
transport but what's been really
interesting regarding skills obviously
it's going to be in the detail but the
government are talking about t levels in
particular but
having spent time with college
principals only a couple of weeks ago i
was hearing how tricky that is with t
levels to get the right businesses to
get businesses to come on board with t
levels i really do believe
apprenticeships are the way to genuinely
level up but it is a part of a holistic
picture trevor that you can't level up
just with skills alone of course they're
important you have to have that
transport system to get people to those
opportunities to learning
when we think about apprenticeships um
actually
the picture hasn't been that fantastic
has it i mean we know that a lot of
businesses uh it is estimated that
something like 5000 big businesses
didn't take up their full entitlement
under the apprenticeship levy and that
400 million
pounds worth of apprenticeship levy
money simply expired because uh you
can't if you don't use it you lose it um
is there anything that you think we need
to do with the apprenticeship
program to make it more user-friendly so
more people can get onto it because
otherwise
uh it's a lot of noise without much
substance isn't it
i absolutely agree and having uh had a
meeting with the ceo of ocado a couple
of years ago when i was the member of
parliament for badly and spent they paid
the levied they can't recruit this is
not right and that's why i'm really
pleased across where sharks should we
support businesses to share that
apprenticeship levy to make sure that
those smaller smes can get the talented
apprentices that that they need in order
to expand but i would also say having uh
visited a really brilliant local company
that's in aerospace produmax
only a couple of weeks ago talking about
apprentices it's really important that
we make sure that those from black asian
and minority ethnic backgrounds also get
that opportunity to get an
apprenticeship with a really fantastic
company that's my approach as the mayor
that's we have some powers over skills
and i was able to launch a six million
pound program to have modular skills
offer for those uh people who've been
made redundant after furlough or young
people have not been able to just get
started after covid so that they can do
shorter programs because there are some
challenges to full-time programs when
people have to pay their bills and earn
a living so it's really an exciting time
for west yorkshire finally we have
devolution i'm six months into the job
but it's a it's a point that now we're
uh able to deliver obviously we want to
work with government to help them
deliver on their leveling up ambitions
and we're here and we're ready to do it
um can i turn to the other big story of
the day as it is pretty much every week
and that is covered um
the health secretary this week
came on a bit like um school head master
and
said that if we didn't do better on mask
wearing and so on then we'd all be back
in detention what's the mood in west
yorkshire
well it is a really troubling time um
let's not forget that west yorkshire has
been in restrictions for most of the 18
months our businesses and our high
streets have really suffered so many
people have lost so much over these last
uh awful 18 months it's uh it's
troubling looking at the next few months
i was able with my limited powers to be
able to mandate for mask wearing in bus
stations obviously sadiq khan has
different powers he could say across all
of transport mass squaring to be a
priority and to be mandated we will be
working with councils to find the best
way towards christmas but of course
let's not forget it was councils that
really supported us during the last few
months whether that was testing tracking
and tracing and finding uh laptops for
kids that didn't have tech that are
rolling out the vaccination program this
is labor councils particularly in west
yorkshire that have delivered for their
community and i know we'll continue to
do so and to try and keep people safe
uh tracy braven um
politics has been consumed in the last
week if i may
raise this with the aftermath of the
death of david amos and you yourself
obviously um
have been close to this issue
do you what's your take uh if i may ask
for you know 30 seconds
does politics need to be kinder and
gentler
well of course and you'll know um how i
came into parliament that terrible
tragedy when we lost joe cox i said to
my family who were worried when i took
up the role it was a once-in-a-lifetime
lightning strike it would never happen
again and sadly here we are five years
later of course politics has to be
kinder we need to also provide mental
health support in our communities people
have suffered a lot we need to make sure
that there is provision to to help those
people who are feeling angry and
frustrated obviously um so david amis is
a a fine uh human and and certainly he
was very kind to me when i was a member
of parliament and an and an inveterate
letter writer i had a number of letters
from him but it's an awful time and
obviously we need to do more and i'm
really pleased that my colleagues in
westminster are taking up the mantle to
make sure that we can certainly in the
online space with the online um bill's
white paper that we can online harms
white paper that we can make sure that
there is legislation to protect people
tracy braven thank you very much indeed
a pleasure
well uh that's all we have time for this
morning uh on wednesday we are going to
be hearing what uh kind of song the
chancellor will be singing i don't
suppose it's going to be we're going to
shower you with money but we will see
and we will be back in a week's time
to consider what's going to happen at
cop26
in the light of all that
[Music]
you